ça fait environ 10 épisodes qu'on parle
de l'importance de la morale désir on a
vu qu'il n'ya bien conçu pouvait entre
autres
combattre la discrimination sauver des
vies réduire notre impact
environnemental et lutter contre les
risques de catastrophe majeure
mais on a aussi vu qu'une liasse en
valeur morale elle est très probablement
empirer les filter bobl sur internet
promouvoir le pit a cliqué l'indignation
augmenter notre addiction au numérique
voir combattre pour sa propre survie et
acquérir toutes les ressources
disponibles
bref l'ia est en train de prendre de
plus en plus de place dans nos sociétés
elle acquiert ainsi de grands pouvoirs
et de grand pouvoir implique de grandes
responsabilités et du coup il est
intéressant de se demander quelle est la
morale d iliad aujourd'hui ou plutôt
qu'est ce qui motive les ira à faire ce
qu'elles font eh bien il se trouve que
la quasi-totalité des ja d'aujourd'hui
repose sur un même principe sesia
cherchent à maximiser un score ou de
façon équivalente à minimiser des sortes
de pertes
c'est quelque chose dont on a déjà parlé
dans l'épisode 9 sur la régression
linéaire une régression linéaire
ça consiste à déterminer un modèle qui
minimisent l'écart entre les prédictions
du modèle et les observations et même
plus précisément la somme des carrés des
écarts entre la théorie et les données
il s'agit là d'un principe très général
la cp de l'épisode 20 détermine l'hyper
plan qui minimise les écarts entre un
nuage de points et un hyper plan li a
donné fixe maximise la probabilité que
vous cliquez sur ses suggestions
elia de youtube maximise le temps que
vous passerez un boîtier des vidéos sur
youtube et de façon très générale les ja
fonctionne souvent avec un principe de
carottes et de bâtons les programmeurs
leur donne des carottes quand elles font
ce que les programmeurs veulent qu'elles
fassent et des coups de bâton quand
elles font ce que les programmeurs ne
veulent pas qu'elle fasse les ja sont
alors programmé pour maximiser les
carottes et minimiser les coups de bâton
mais si vous y voyez une analogie avec
les humains bah oui en fait
historiquement le formalisme des
carottes et des bâtons que l'on appelle
aussi l'apprentissage par renforcement
c'est quelque chose d'inspirer de la
biologie comportementale que l'on
associe souvent à des chercheurs comme
pavlov ou szpiner
en particulier skinner s'est amusé à
récompenser des pigeons avec non pas des
carottes mais des graines à chaque fois
que les pigeons faisaient l'action
suggéré par un mot écrit les pigeons a
pris ainsi à associer certains mots avec
certaines actions afin de recevoir leurs
carottes
et là on parle de pillon mais ce genre
d'apprentissage pour renforcement est
présent chez l'homme aujourd'hui
typiquement à l'école où nous engueuler
quand on fait des fautes d'orthographe
et on nous donne des bonnes notes quand
on pense à appliquer le théorème de
pythagore au triangle rectangle et ce
genre d'apprentissage a lieu bien au
delà du cadre de l'école on la retrouve
aussi dans la loi ou dans la religion
surtout dans la région d'ailleurs la
punition est la récompense que du
réserve est infiniment plus motivante
qu'aucune de celle qui peut appuyer la
loi si dieu veut être pu lire ce sera
une éternité de souffrance et si dieu
veut récompenser ce sera une éternité de
bonheur donc l'enjeu est immense
l'éternité c'est long surtout vers la
fin
dieu tient une énorme carotte et un
énorme bâton c'est un truc sexuelle la
loi en comparaison elle a un tout petit
bâton et pas vraiment de carottes et
alors on pourrait croire que ce genre
d'apprentissage un petit peu bateau est
limité mais l'espoir d'une carotte ou la
peur d'un bâton peuvent soulever des
montagnes
ou en tout cas conduit à une
intelligence stratégique stupéfiante par
exemple en 2015 l'ia de deep net a
atteint des performances de niveau
humain ou jeu d'arcade d'atari en
exploitant uniquement les couleurs des
pixels à l'écran et en ayant pour
carottes plus corps du jeu l'objectif de
maximiser les carottes a suffit à
motiver cette ia pour concevoir en elle
un modèle du jeu et une recherche de
stratégies sophistiquées et ça a bien
sûr c'est en 2015
aujourd'hui les ja pas renforcement sont
capables de prouesses toujours plus
sophistiquées en atteignant des niveaux
humain ou surhumain à des jeux comme
starcraft dota 2 ou capture the flag est
d'ailleurs la performance de 2018 à
capture de flag est particulièrement
impressionnante
parce que capture de flingues est un jeu
collaboratif qui exige de lire qu'elle
comprenne ce que ses coéquipiers humains
ou ia ou l'intention de faire l'autre
exemple bien connu est celui du jeu de
go avec notamment la défaite de lys
idole contre alpha gore 2016 le cas
d'hugo est d'ailleurs particulièrement
intéressant parce que la carotte est
relativement abstraite
oui parce que dans ce cas la carotte et
la victoire en fin de partie et le bâton
la défaite mais cette carotte et ce
bâton n'interviennent qu'en fin de
partie
or une partie de go est souvent très
longue l'astuce d'alpha go flûte alors
de s'armer d'une estimation de la
probabilité d'avoir la carotte en fin de
partie et c'est cette probabilité de
carottes khalfa go maximise au cours de
la partie
on parle aussi de fonctions d'évaluation
et je vous renvoie vers la vidéo de
david sur science étonnante pour savoir
plus alors il ya quelques détails
techniques
additionnel que je passe sous silence
mais en gros cette fonction
d'évaluations correspondent plus ou
moins une fonction que l'on appelle la
fonction cul oui ça s'appelle la
fonction qu c'est pas moi qui ai choisi
la fonction q10 alia pour chaque état du
jeu et pour chaque action entreprise
quelle est la quantité de carottes futur
qu'on peut espérer une fois qu connu il
suffira ensuite de choisir à tout
instant l'action qui maximise la
fonction qu étant donné l'état du jeu
oui encore des histoires important de
facteurs d ce compte des carottes du
futur et de dilemme exploration versus
exploitation sur lesquels il faudrait
disserter mais je vais me contenter de
textes à l'écran et je vais passer tout
ça sous silence à l'oral résoudre le
problème d'apprentissage correspondait
alors à bien estimer la fonction qu on
parle d'apprentissage de la fonction
cube ou de cul learning et on cherche
souvent à estimer cette fonction qu à
l'aide de nombreux outils plus
classiques comme l'apprentissage
supervisé à partir d'exemples et les
fameux réseaux de neurones profond ou
deep learning
mais oublions ces détails de
l'estimation de la fonction qu pour
aujourd'hui
de nos jours il semble que le paradigme
du cul learning soit le paradigme le
plus puissant pour concevoir désir dans
des systèmes d'interactions complexes et
tout le principe du cul learning c'est
tout bêtement d'estimer les probables
futurs carottes et coups de bâton quand
dans un état donné ont choisi
d'entreprendre telle ou telle action
bref les carottes et les bâtons se sont
en fait des outils redoutablement
puissant pour motiver les ja a
longuement réfléchir pour mieux
comprendre le monde qui les entoure et à
prendre des décisions qui amèneront très
probablement à des conséquences qui sont
celles que les programmeurs soit si bien
que cette approche semble aussi être le
fondement d y aller plus puissantes du
futur en tout cas il semble que ce soit
essentiellement ainsi que fonctionne via
de youtube cette ia possède un score qui
est le temps que les utilisateurs
passent à regarder des vidéos pendant
disons un mois donné et pour maximiser
ses carottes l'ia de youtube va chercher
à optimiser les suggestions de vidéos
pour que les utilisateurs cliquent reste
et reviennent aussi longtemps que
possible sur youtube
mais alors ce comportement de l'ia de
youtube il est tout à fait légale et on
a même tendance à dire qu'il est
parfaitement innocents cependant même si
j'en ai déjà parlé dans l'épisode 29
j'aimerais insister encore une fois sur
les conséquences potentiellement
désastreuses de ce comportement de
y'a de youtube parce qu'à bien y
réfléchir même si ça serait exagéré de
dire que l'ia de youtube en serait
responsable
on peut néanmoins constater que youtube
a favorisé la prolifération et le
partage d'idées très dangereuse par
exemple de nombreuses vidéos se
positionnant fermement contre les
vaccins ont été rendues virale par
youtube youtube a donc été un catalyseur
du mouvement antivaccin alors ça ne veut
pas dire que les vidéos anti vaccins
sont majoritaires cependant à cause de
la personnalisation des contenus
suggérés aux utilisateurs
on a des phénomènes de filter bubbles
qui apparaissent et de la même manière
que mes suggestions contiennent beaucoup
de vidéos de maths des suggestions des
anti vaccins ont probablement beaucoup
de vidéos anti vaccins et ça pose
problème parce que les sciences sont
assez univoque ne pas vacciner votre
enfant celle exposée à de nombreuses
maladies mortelles et des maladies
horrible qui plus est facilitée la
prolifération des contenus anti vague
sans certaines communautés peut donc
être vue comme un acte criminel ou du
moins un acte qui a conduit à des
conséquences très tragique d'une
certaine manière lié à de youtube a
partiellement causé la mort de jeunes
enfants alors je prends là l'exemple des
vaccins mais les idées dangereuses qui
se propage à travers youtube qui sont en
fait très nombreuses par exemple suggéré
aux utilisateurs des vidéos de 4,4
promeut la consommation d'engins très
polluant ce qui pose tous les problèmes
que l'on connaît de même recommandé à
des utilisateurs des vidéos extrêmement
sexistes revient à normaliser les
inégalités de joueurs dans nos sociétés
auprès de certains individus et notez
bien que dans tous ces cas il ya de
youtube n'a pas de mauvaises intentions
en agissant ainsi elle rend les
utilisateurs plus fidèles à youtube ce
qui augmente le witch tale et fait donc
gagner tout plein de carottes alia de
youtube cette ia fait uniquement ce
qu'il faut faire pour maximiser les
récompenses qu'on lui a promise d'une
certaine manière on peut dire que la
seule morale de l'ia de youtube c'est de
maximiser le witch time et ça c'est
moralement discutable et ça a des
conséquences potentiellement tragique et
ça surtout malheureusement c'est la
morale de la quasi-totalité des i had
aujourd'hui on les motive à coups de
carottes et de bâtons ces carottes et
ses bâtons ne sont pas liés à des
valeurs morales humaines
mais du coup pour maximiser leurs
carottes et minimiser leurs coups de
bâton saisie à risque fort
d'entreprendre des actions qui ont pour
dommages collatéraux des phénomènes que
nous autres humains juges ont
quasi-unanimement moralement
indésirables l'aderf en a parlé de
catastrophe planétaire et du rôle que
pouvait jouer il n'ya pour essayer
d'empêcher ces risques planétaire et
hissler nous demande aussi des
nanomachines tueuse est un scénario
plausible et j'ai envie de dire que
c'est extrêmement difficile de dire que
ça une probité 0 d'arrivée encore une
fois quand on raisonne par rapport à
tous ces scénarios du futur
la question n'est pas de savoir si un
scénario donné va arriver la question
c'est est ce qu'il est probable qu'il
arrive et sachant tous les scénarios
possibles de fin du monde
il faut à peu près ajouté toutes ces
différentes probabilité pour se rendre
compte que lorsqu'on cumule tous ces
scénarios possibles il ya quand même une
probabilité qui me semble non
négligeable qu'il y ait une catastrophe
planétaire d'ici la fin du siècle et en
particulier sur une anomalie tueuse dont
par le hissent leur en effet ces races
et ça peut être assez dangereux
notamment pas nécessairement parce que
leur but est de tuer ce qui me paraît
peut-être même plus probable que des
nanomachines de tueuse parce que bon
pour tuer on a déjà les drones tueurs ce
qui est ce qu'ils seront qui seront sans
doute plus facile à mettre en place
surtout sur les imprimantes 3d qu'on
arrive à avoir des modèles bref je
passais sur la partie aux boutures
mais si je parle juste d'un point de vue
occidental c'est qui pourrait arriver
c'est qu'on conçoivent des nanomachines
qui sont des réplicateurs de bonne manne
qui est réplicateurs de von neumann
ce sont des structures qui sont capables
de trouver des objets autour d'elle à
partir de cette matière première est ce
qu'ils sont capables de se répliquer et
ça correspond à un modèle assez simple
qu'on prévoit d'ailleurs pour
l'exploration spatiale spatiale et dont
j'ai déjà parlé dans l'épisode 27
lorsque j'ai joué au jeu des trombones
aujourd'hui on sait déjà qu'il y à des
molécules qui ont un peu près s'être
propriété notamment les clients qui sont
des protéines
qui ont une structure spatiale qui n'est
pas la structure spatiale de qu'on
aimerait qu'elle faisait et qui peuvent
poser des frais qui peuvent être mortels
tout simplement je vous renvoie vers la
vidéo de cette étonnante sur les prix
notamment pour à en savoir plus et ça me
paraît assez difficile l'exploit
possibilité qu'il y ait plein d'autres
molécules qui auront cette faculté à se
répliquer assez facilement avec peu de
matériel notamment à ces possibles que
concevoir la première de ces molécules
soit une étape difficile c'est pour ça
que l'évolution n'a pas su créer la
première étape de ces molécules
mais c'est possible que avec des
techniques d'ingénierie on arrive à
créer cette première molécule et si
cette molécule nous échapper le poids se
répliquer et un truc qui s'auto
répliques comme ça s'ils sont au de
réplication est plus rapide que son taux
de mortalité une certaine manière si
elle se croit plus vite qu'elle ne meure
on aura une croissance exponentielle qui
pourraient être potentiellement très
rapide du nombre de ces nano machines
aux deux de ces molécules long ou enfin
des nanomachines et l'art la secret
place qui serait potentiellement
extrêmement dangereuse puisque une
croissance exponentielle ça à perdre
très rapidement les limites physiques
un truc comme ça qu'ils se réplique très
facilement partout sur terre c'est un
truc qui me ferait vraiment vrac c'est
vraiment un risque la licence yali
l'équipe a complètement anéantir
énormément de choses et qui pourrait
être également très difficile à
combattre
c'est pour celle que le risque
globalement des nanotechnologies est
ainsi intériste qui me semble devoir
être pris au sérieux alors je suis pas
du tout expert ben je sais pas du tout
quelle est la probabilité d'avoir de
tels événements mais me semble que
l'état la connaissance actuelle en
nanotechnologie est suffisamment limité
pour qu'on ait du mal à exclure
complètement ce genre de possibilités
et ça ça m'amène un raisonnement fait
par nick bostrom dans son livre super
intelligence où il parle de ce risque de
nanotechnologies et il se pose la
question on va
sachant qu'il ya des risques
existentielle est bon il ya aussi
intelligence artificielle qui a ses
propres risque existentiel encore une
fois les épisodes notamment 26 et 28
pour parler
pouvoir déjà ce que j'ai dit sur les
risque existentiel que peuvent causer
une heure et demie à deux niveaux humain
et le truc aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
très difficile de freiner le progrès
tellement d'intérêt économique rend un
show que c'est assez difficile
d'imaginer qu'il n'y aura pas énormément
de recharge pour que la création d'une
ligue à deux niveaux humain en ce moment
il ya énormément de recherches qui vont
plus ou moins dans cette direction et du
coup c'est un risque qui est très
difficile à exclure le risque de
l'intelligence artificielle de niveau
humain le risque d'un à noter que j'ai
évidemment est très difficile à exclure
mais du coup il ya une question de
timing si les nanotechnologies
apparaissent avant l'intelligence
artificielle de niveau humain alors on
aura d'abord le risque existentiel des
nanotechnologies qui deviennent des
régulateurs de nomades ou des trucs
vraiment très dangereux et ensuite le
risque de l'intelligence artificielle
pour pouvoir survivre 21e siècle va
falloir survivre à cela seul de ces deux
risques donc la probabilité de survivre
va être diminuée de la somme des
probabilités des deux événements
maintenant si on arrive à faire l'
inverse c'est à dire si on arrive à le
faire d'abord l'intelligence
artificielle de niveau humain et ensuite
les technologies arriverait après à ce
moment là on pourra utiliser les
intelligences artificielles de niveau 1
pour mieux contrôler les risques et sans
doute qu'une intelligence artificielle
au niveau humain pourrait même peu
essentiellement anéantir les risques des
nanotechnologies
parce qu'elle comprendra ça beaucoup
mieux que nous surtout si elle atteint
un niveau surhumains et du coup la
probabilité de survie au 21ème siècle ne
serait que finalement la probabilité de
survivre à l'intelligence artificielle
de niveau humain donc ça c'est un
argument de bochum pour dire que en fait
c'est super important que l'intelligence
artificielle de niveau humain
apparaissent avant les autres risque
existentiel potentiellement
catastrophiques comme les
nanotechnologies les biotechnologies
mais disons que les drones tueurs ce
petit raisonnement de bostrom il conduit
à la conclusion qu'en fait il faut
accélérer autant que possible la
recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle
même si l'intelligence artificielle de
niveau humain notamment posent un risque
existentiel scène plus racée contre
intuitive mais que je trouve assez assez
convaincant soit finalement je pense que
c'est assez important de développer la
recherche en devenir
même si le problème de la morale désire
me semble encore encore à l'âge de
pierre pas à part de ça du coup vraiment
une des priorités vraiment aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment travailler sur la
recherche sur la morale les ja je pense
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il ya
vraiment pas encore assez de gens qui
s'intéressent à ce problème et surtout
qui parle sérieusement de ce problème ou
qui prennent au sérieux ce problème est
qu'ils ne le moc pas et en particulier
beaucoup trop de chercheurs en
intelligence artificielle qui prennent
plaisir à se moquer des gens qui
travaillent sur les problèmes de risques
risques causés par une intelligence
artificielle
enfin dominique and the man pose la
question par rapport à lla capable de
prédire le chaos
donc en fait le titre de l'article de
quanta magazine est assez musclé ligne
est assez trompeur puisque non liés à
n'arrive pas à prédire les sytèmes
chaotique puisque les systèmes chaotique
ont quelque chose de vos amants assez
fondamentalement imprévisibles notamment
le principe du cas où c'est justement qu
une imprécision dans les données
observées fait que le futur est
finalement imprévisible à partir d'un
certain temps peu importe le niveau
intelligence que l'on a si les données
sont pas suffisamment précises et dans
un système chaotique une toute petite
erreur dans une mesure même de la 1%
peut causer des changements de
comportements radicaux et donc même une
ia n'est pas capable de faire quelques
prédictions que ce soit cependant ce qui
a été réussi et c'est donc par l'article
de compte et magazines ce sont des
prédictions à plus long terme que ce que
d'autres méthodes plus classiques qui
suivent par exemple les principes de la
physique arrive à faire typiquement
quand on parle de système chaotique on
aime avoir une unité de temps qu'on
appelle le temps de lire tout neuf qui
correspond au temps à partir duquel
en gros en ordre de grandeur le système
deviendra complètement imprévisible et
bong a généralement atteindre le temps
de la pin up en terme de prédiction
c'est fiable c'est déjà un problème très
très difficile et sesia certaines dia
dont certains problèmes ont réussi à
atteindre plusieurs fois à faire des
prédictions à plusieurs temps de l'iap
neuf mais bon ce sera jamais à plus de
100 temps de l'es9 et ce sera clairement
jamais à plus d'un milliard de fois le
temps de lire plus le pont neuf
c'est mathématiquement impossible de
faire plus de prêts si c'est quand même
bon de rappeler qu'une intelligence
artificielle même super intelligence
c'est pas non plus un truc qui c'est
tout c'est pas du tout une momie quelque
chose de mission ça reste quelque chose
qui résonne à partir de données pour
faire des prédictions puisque ce calcul
là est bien mieux fait que ce qu'on sait
faire nous mais ça ne reste que ce genre
de calcul que sait faire que ce sera
fair une intelligence artificielle et en
particulier sera limitée par les données
complètes qu'elle pourra avoir accès
nous on pouvait pas faire de bonnes
prédictions vous pouvez pas être
intelligent si vous n'avez pas des
données pour devenir intelligent et puis
tant qu'à parler des limites des ia du
futur les ja du futur seront également
nécessairement limités par les limites
de puissance de calcul en particulier
une théorique la théorie de la
complexité algorithmique qu'il qui dit
ce qui ne peut pas être résolu en temps
raisonnable tels que l'âge de l'univers
disons et notamment il ya les pointes de
cryptographie qui sont pas résolues bhl
a priori en un temps plus grand que
l'âge de l'univers et sesia seront pas
capables de casser les codes de
cryptographie pour cette raison à moins
d'utiliser un ordinateur quantique moi
je vous renvoie vers la vidéo que j'ai
fait avec string theory notamment j'ai
parlé un petit peu de cryptographie post
quantique et j'espère qu'ils avaient
aimé cette vidéo sur l'apprentissage pas
renforcement et du coup quand les ja
d'aujourd'hui acquiert une fonction
d'objectifs dans les prochaines vidéos
on parlera beaucoup de cette fonction
objectif est de comment
la concevoir notamment si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à la locale a
commenté à la partie pensez à vous
abonner pour les pilotes version hip hop
l'ordre et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois si dieu n'existe pas non
tout n'est pas permis tout n'est pas
moralement permis il n'est pas
moralement permis de tuer quelqu'un
comme ça juste pour rire que dieu existe
ou non pour nous punir de l'avoir fait
non c'est pas faux mais du coup quand
même vaut mieux croire que dieu est là
pour nous punir au moins sa force morale
et bien en fait gérés plutôt que ça nous
empêche d'être immoral et c'est pas tout
à fait la même chose et en fait on
pourrait même montré que ça nous empêche
aussi d'être moral states action ajusté
1 0 par action conséquence en action est
en baisse l'action state street et stuck
on développe agent s to maximize du
golfe persique en actions est un maximum
à 16h est extrêmement grave